I would say a bond between the inmate
and the horse is one of the most
important things that they learn when
they actually start to bond with that
horse they will become better trainers
they will become better people I think
that's good that they feel that much
pride in their horses it's good to have
pride in something especially in prison
[Music]
that goes right up behind his ears a
little bit with with that rope
now when that gets up there in my job
I'm pretty good my name is Hank curry
I'm the head horse trainer here at the
Northern Nevada Correctional Center I've
been here 15 years now and I'm in charge
of about 20 to 25 inmates
we're taking a completely wild horse and
trying to domesticate them get them
where they're a gentle usable horse the
inmates put in applications to come to
work out here and according to their
behavior in prison we review all of that
and try to decide whether or not they
could possibly become horse trainers to
start out with we take a totally wild
horse and I have my guys actually put
them in a round drill we don't allow
them to rope them or anything else they
have to actually make contact with their
hands most of the inmates that may be
ridden a horse once or twice in their
life so it takes a lot of guts and it
takes a lot of determination this guy
right here didn't want nothing to do
with me and now he's you know my little
buddy and he follows me everywhere I go
it's just a moment where you bond you
know and you become you know like best
friends this guy only did it within the
last few weeks it's pretty amazing I
mean I'm not doing time until I go back
to camp you know and that's when the
clock starts for me as far as realizing
where I'm at when I'm out here I'm free
in the last few years we've developed a
lot of horses that have been used by the
Fish and Game ordinance the Forestry
Service the Sheriff's Department
actually has a amount of group and those
were horses trained by this program I
think that you know this job is kind of
inspirational it's not like regular
prison where everybody's running around
being foul-mouthed you know being a
tough guy and everything else doesn't
work out here horses don't care who you
are how big or how tough you are
they will equalize the playing field if
you want to play tough I see a great
deal of change in all these guys they
seem to mature they're functioning they
know how to work you know how to hold a
job so often it's it's changed their
lives
[Music]
[Music]
playing Hamlet has helped me ask
questions of myself that usually I we
buried deep inside I never thought I'd
do anything like this to be or not to be
that is the question my name is Leslie
career I'm the founding managing
director of Marin Shakespeare Company
the methodology of our program is
inspired by drama therapy
it creates laughter in the room and it
breaks down barriers between races and
ages and groups it's very beautiful work
and we've seen a lot of transformation
most of the men in the group don't have
any theatre experience and haven't
studied Shakespeare before so when we
start talking about the plays and the
characters they're just bringing their
own personal life experience to the
conversation when I first came in I
thought I would never act again I
attended college back in Nebraska in
1968 and 69 I was a co major theater and
music when I came into prison there is
this certain demeanor that you have to
establish so in essence I'm acting on a
day to day basis just to survive to be
able to be up on that stage letting the
true Steve come through
but in the person of the character
that's the freedom I get or that's what
I hope comes out when I do Polonius
pastoral historical comical this rolous
is so challenging that it makes me go
through the entire gamut of emotions
he's so conflicted that a man I must
have pulled from every facet of my life
I've been betrayed before I've had my
trust broken
I've done really horrible things to
people you know in a rage like Hamlet's
done well you may see the inmost part of
you what will that do will not murder me
over the years I've learned that I have
to give back that I also have to own up
and look at what I did
realistically I'm hoping through other
things that I do my acting I can give
something back to society I've been able
to use all of my past experience and
kind of channel it into this character I
hope that playing my role helps the
other inmates here feel like they're
part of the story this doesn't just help
me escape this helps them escape too it
also helps me a gain a lot of empathy
for you know what other people are going
through it's uh tearing open old wounds
to try to embody this to bring the
character alive and bring other people
within the story it's it's difficult but
it's also really cathartic it helps it
helps me heal in this cruel world draw
thy breath in pain
to tell my story the rest
silence
[Applause]
[Music]
the day I was going to sign my papers to
start working there were 3,000 inmates
out there working iron and I was like
what did I get myself into here my name
is karma Shaheen I'm the career
technical and educator for cosmetology
at Valley State Prison Foreman when I
tell people that I work teaching
cosmetology in a men's prison a lot of
people are shocked by it they're
surprised they didn't even think that it
was available this program takes
approximately two years and they have to
have 1,600 hours completed in order to
take the State Board Exam there is a
waiting list to get into this class and
in order to get into this class an
inmate has to meet certain behavioral
and educational standards why you come
into my classroom you're going to treat
each other with respect and common
courtesy and there's no boundaries in
here which is gonna relax your facial
muscles and improve your blush your face
my name is Juan Ruiz Walla I'm here at
rally state prison in Chowchilla
California my favorite part of the class
is the skin care part of it which
includes like the face shows eyebrows
makeup I like to just see my clients
relaxed and the
with me with it's real personal and
being in prison they teach you not to
touch each other not to touch staff it
goes against the norm of what people see
about prison on TV you know ex-gang
members come in with tattoos on their
face all over their body is not
something that you see out there working
in a beauty salon is putting a line on a
different side of the prison system I do
treat them as human beings and I'm not
here to punish them I'm just here to
show them a skill that I have and it
happens to be in a prison I have more
empathy for people no because of doing
this type of work when they get their
license it's like I've gotten my license
for the first time all over again it's
very rewarding I'm a city boy I'm from
New York never seeing in a cow or
anything like that hanging out with a
mule it's pretty cool you'll probably
won't have an opportunity like that and
rest of my life
[Music]
we are at the Monroe County Sheriff's
Office animal farms on the grounds of
the detention center we have the
capacity to have 700 inmates in all
three of our Jail facilities this is the
main jail and we're the only facility of
this kind in the country that has a
exotic seriatim jail it started out with
just farm animals and now I have exotic
animals of all varieties kinkajous are
from the rainforests of Central and
South America that's the bird we call
the I love you bird and he is such a
camera hog we only take in animals that
have been abandoned abused confiscated
or donated hi Tucker we don't purchase
any of the animals and they're here for
their life this is a forever home for
them I've been here just for a year you
know and these guys are doing a life
sentence I'm oh sorry Kramer gonna wake
you up pretty girl today I have four
inmates every day they come down here to
feed water and clean and then to spend
time with the animals what's going on
buddy you're gonna get out pretty soon
mandatory rec the farm is one of the
jobs in this facility that you could
actually be outside all day
at number two got to interact with a
bunch of rare cool animals like Kramer
here he's got the little curl on the top
of his head that's why we call Kramer
just as he or he he was uh he was saved
from a slaughterhouse and he's a lot
better off do you think working with the
animals helps the inmates with their
rehabilitation I've seen a lot of very
positive changes I've seen people that
come down here and are completely scared
of animals and by the end of their time
here then e of them bring their families
back to actually show them what they
were doing when they were incarcerated
I'm so happy to be out here when I first
came he was like not even this big
painting and now look at you
[Music]
you
[Music]